hi Jason you've used non-relational
nosql databases in production projects
hi Martin yes I have I've learned a lot
along the way about what works well and
what doesn't in some real life
applications I'll be happy to share with
you we'd love to learn from
[Music]
you so Jason we met years ago at
developer conferences in London and in
California I learned that you speak at
conferences about Firebase and Google
Cloud uh which made you a certified
Google developer expert and you're also
a Google Cloud certified professional
architect and you run your own business
418 dodev yes Martin I always like to
keep busy and maybe this video should be
about time management instead of
databases uh it's sometimes hard for me
to work and pick up groceries on the
same day well if you enjoy something you
love it's easier to find the time why is
words now years ago in my first job they
taught me about relational databases
that use SQL SQL uh the data is in
tables and those tables are linked by
IDs and uh any system built back in
those days used relational databases uh
but then non-relational databases came
along well with the web we needed a way
to build more scalable
applications non-relational databases
filled that need these databases store
data in documents applications only need
to read a single document for each
entity which puts less load on the
server so these databases can handle a
lot of traffic got it now you've used uh
non-relational databases in production
on some major projects right right and
I've used them for everything from
simple mobile applications to large
Enterprise iot projects consuming tens
of millions of events per day and that's
what I wanted to ask Jason what lessons
have you learned about non-relational
databases in these real life
projects it comes down to three
architecture decisions when to use
relational versus non-relational
databases how to design a good
non-relational data model
and when to choose direct client access
versus an API layer excellent let's dig
into each of those um so the first
decision on your list is uh when to use
relational versus non-relational
database uh tell us more about that well
this is a big topic but my rule of thumb
is use a non-relational database when
the number of reads is much greater than
the number of writes could you give us
an example so a consumer facing user
interface may be a good example in many
web apps and mobile apps there can be
hundreds or even thousands of times more
reads than writes mhm yeah I recognize
that in my own app usage if most
database operations are read operations
a non-relational database can be faster
and cheaper the data is denormalized
which means no complex joins those joins
between Labs can lead to slow
performance um and increase cost in
regular relational
databases right I've written some pretty
hairy SQL joins in relational databases
in previous jobs also non-relational
databases often require less code to
integrate with that means higher
developer
productivity and there are serous
nonrelational databases which means less
operations work once the app is up and
running that sounds pretty good uh would
you ever use a relational database uh
like I was taught back in my first job
yes relational databases are great for
tasks where you are making many rights
or if you need to run complex queries
for things like
reporting okay let's say a
non-relational database would be a good
fit for my application which one should
I choose well as you can see I'm wearing
a Firebase t-shirt so I would normally
recommend Cloud fir store because it's
easy to deploy and maintain plus the
Firebase SDK is really easy to work with
and the Firebase team have some great
tutorials on their YouTube
channel there are other non-relational
databases in Google Cloud platform like
big table and Fir store data store mode
but fir store native mode is a good
choice for most
applications very good now the second
decision in your list is about data
model design now I'm pretty good at
designing regular relational data models
but how do you design a non relational
data model well first use the
nonrelational database as it's intended
with Collections and
documents put enough data into each
document that you won't need to fetch
multiple
documents if you use a relational data
model with entities linked by IDs you'll
require more read operations which will
increase complexity latency and cost got
it uh how do we decide what Fields
belong in each document my rule of thumb
is the data model should follow the user
interface got it uh the data model
should follow the UI uh that's a simple
rule to remember uh all good rules
usually
are uh but I may have data that appears
in multiple places uh for example I
might look at a vehicle document and
want to see see the address of the
garage where it's uh parked overnight um
but this same address would also be in
other car documents so where should I
store that common address in a
relational database each table holds a
single instance of some data and they
are connected together with joins that
makes it easy to write a field but it
adds load to the server with every
single right because multiple tables
have to be
joined in a non-relational database we
can save on processing time and cost by
replicating the data so to answer your
question we copy the address to each
vehicle's document we call this
denormalization I see how that would
make for fast reads you only read one
document uh but what happens when we
need to update that address do we have
to change it in every single document
yes we will have to update every
document where this data appears and
how's that efficient uh to update it in
multiple places well Martin as we
discussed earlier in an application
where the number of reads far outweighs
the number of Rights we have to make a
tradeoff when we denormalize the data
must be copied whenever an update is
made however Cloud fir store makes this
really easy for us using update triggers
and Cloud functions oh I like Cloud
functions
uh tell me how you to design this so
when you update a document in firestore
it can trigger a cloud
function that cloud function can read
the updated garage address and update
each of the vehicles documents that are
in that garage with the new
address great I like that the trigger
does this automatically so the app
developer doesn't have to remember to do
it every time they update a document uh
now your third design decision from your
list that is to choose direct client
access versus an API layer what does
that mean well there are two ways that
client apps can access firestore through
a service side API layer that you build
yourself or directly from the client
using the Firebase
SDK right uh I have access to fire store
directly from a web client in a previous
project I avoided writing a lot of
server side code that way that's one
great advantage of accessing fire store
directly from the client if you have to
write less code you will get your app to
Market sooner also less code means lower
maintenance costs and hopefully fewer
bugs and there are fir store sdks for
web iOS Android flutter and unity that's
right it takes a lot of work to build a
production API that can handle things
like spotty internet connections cash
ing attacks load balancing
authentication and authorization the
Firebase sdks take care of all of that
for you right just last week I had to
build an API that implemented paging and
just a simple thing like that it's I
mean it's pretty complex to to test it
and write all the code for it uh I
wouldn't want to have to build all of
the other things you mentioned for every
API I build yes indeed and another great
advantage of direct client access with
the five base SDK is that clients can be
notified in real time when your data
changes in firestore so let's revisit
our Fleet Management app if each car has
a GPS device and reports its location
you could display a map that shows all
the cars in real time whenever a car's
position is updated by firestore it will
then push the update to all web and
mobile apps so they can adjust that
car's position on the map in real time
very nice uh but if users are accessing
the database directly how do you handle
authorization if you use the Firebase
SDK you define security rules and these
handle the
authorization the rules tell firestore
who is allowed to read or write each
document in the database based on the
authentication token that they get at
login so let's go back to our Fleet
Management app example we want to keep
Financial details of the car in the
database like maybe the purchase price
and so on if they're filled in the main
vehicle document whoever can read that
document can also read those financial
related
fields by putting the finance data in a
separate document in a subcollection of
that vehicle document we can limit
access to it got it uh direct client
access sounds pretty great um do you use
it in all your applications
Jason yes but not for all use cases in
our example above we were able to
restrict client access using F store
security rules but let's say we want to
expose this data to a thirdparty
application with a custom data model for
that we can create a service side API
which will bundle this data into a
single response and by providing that
API layer you make sure that both your
clients apps and third parties can call
it that's right with an API layer it's
also easier to optimize performance and
Cost Plus you can remap the data model
to suit your needs uh perform maybe some
simple aggregations or even combine it
with data from other sources but there's
nothing to stop you using a mix of
direct client access and API access in
the same application all right uh let's
recap uh we talked about when to use a
relational database two how to design a
good data model for it and three when to
use direct database access from clients
uh thanks for sharing your expertise
with us Jason happy to share I've seen
non-relational databases increase
productivity and performance in many of
my customer systems and where can
viewers get more details on how to
create an application with fir store I
know just the person to
ask hey P
Martin and I have just been chatting
about Cloud fir store can you tell
people where they can get started hey
Jason I'm sure I can hi Martin you can
find loads of resources on the Firebase
YouTube channel and at firebase.com
where there are many Fantastic guides
and tutorials thanks puff it was great
to see you you too Jason and thanks
Martin for letting me Gate Crash Your
show no problem you're always welcome
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for Jason or me
please add a comment below also let me
know if there are other servess topics
you'd like to see in future episodes I
read every single comment until next
[Music]
time